So remember that we need
the load length and
the store conditional to behave
like a single atomic instruction so
that writes by other processors cannot
come in between them without us knowing.
Well this is how it happens.
We do a load length from
a lock variable to R1, and
then we do a store conditional
of R2 into the lock variable.
And what we need is that if the load
link finds the lock available and
we try to do a store conditional,
then the store conditional should
only succeed if the lock is still
available at the time we try that.
If somebody else has
written into the lock,
then store conditional needs to fail.
The key for that is that if we snoop
a write to lockvar at any time,
we put a 0 in the link register.
So if the load link loads
the lock variable, and
we see that it's free and
we try to do a store conditional, but
somebody beats us to it, then the store
will fail because it will observe
that the link register doesn't
match the address of the lockvar.
So the load link/store conditional
really are relying on the coherence
where we observe write
by others to make sure
that if the store conditional succeeds,
it can guarantee that
nobody else grabbed a lock between
when we checked the lock and
when we think we grabbed it,
really by writing a busy value into it.
Now note that the load link/store
conditional are atomic by themselves.
We don't need actually to use
a lock to make this atomic.
So some of the critical sections
that would just lock something,
increment a variable and then unlock
the lock, can now directly be
implemented using load link and store
conditional on the variable itself.
By load linking the variable
itself into R1, incrementing R1,
store conditional of R1
back into the variable.
And now we need to check if the R1 as
a result of the store conditional became
a 0, in which case somebody else was
trying to do the same thing, and we
didn't succeed in doing this atomically,
in which case we just try again.
So eventually we will succeed in this.
We will load, and
we will manage to store it before
somebody else beats us to it.
So if another thread is doing the exact
same thing here, let's say we both load.
Now both of us link to the variable,
we both increment, we both stores.
Whoever does the first
store will succeed.
Whoever does the second store
is going to fail because by that time
their link is broken by the first store.
So that's how, for example,
we can do atomic increments and
all sorts of other things that
involve only one memory location.
So very simple critical
sections like this can
actually be directly implemented
with load link/store
conditional without even
needing locks anymore.
We can use load link and store
conditional directly on the variable
itself, and we no longer need
an actual lock around it.
For more complicated critical sections,
such as those that access multiple
variables, however, load link/store
conditional doesn't work well.
But we can still use load link/store
conditional to actually implement
the lock variable here without
needing complicated algorithms.